LARGER CONSPIRACY.
THAT JUST AHEAD.
FIRST TONIGHT, HOURS AGO
PROSECUTORS IN CHICAGO DROPPED
ALL CHARGERS AGAINST JUSSIE
SMOLLETT.
HE WAS FACING 16 FELONY COUNTS
FOR FAKING AN ELABORATE HATE
CRIME AGAINST HIMSELF BACK IN
JANUARY.
POLICE SAY HE HIRED TWO NIGERIAN
BODY BUILDERS TO HANG A NOOSE ON
HIS NECK AND POOR WHICH ON HIM.
BECAUSE THAT KIND OF THING
HAPPENS A LOT IN DOWNTOWN
CHICAGO AND WINTER.
HE THEN TOLD REPORTERS HE WOULD
BITE ASSAULTED BY TWO WHITE
RACIST TRUMP SUPPORTER'S.
AS OF TONIGHT, POLICE BELIEVE HE
WAS LONG ABOUT ALL OF THAT.
SO DO PROSECUTORS.
THEY SAID SO YET AGAIN TODAY.
AND YET THE STATE OF ILLINOIS IS
SOMEHOW FOR SOME REASON DUMPING
THE CASE ANYWAY.
IN EXCHANGE FOR THE $100,000 HE
HAS ALREADY PAID AND BOND HE
WILL WALK FREE.
AS RECORD WILL BE EXPUNGED AND
EVERYTHING WILL BE RETURNED TO
NORMAL.
HE DESCRIBED HIS DECISION AS A
VICTORY, NOT JUST FOR HIM BUT
FOR THE BROADER CAUSE OF CIVIL
RIGHTS.
>> I'VE BEEN TRUTHFUL AND
CONSISTENT ON EVERY LEVEL.
I WOULD NOT BE MY MOTHER'S SON
IF I WAS CAPABLE OF ONE DROP OF
WHAT I WAS ACCUSED OF.
THIS HAS BEEN A DIFFICULT TIME.
ONE OF THE WORST OF MY ENTIRE
LIFE.
I AM A MAN OF FAITH AND I HAVE A
MAN THAT HAS KNOWLEDGE OF MY
HISTORY AND I WOULD NOT BRING MY
FAMILY, OUR LIVES OR THE
MOVEMENT THROUGH THIS.
I WOULD NOT.
I WOULD LIKE NOTHING MORE THAN
TO JUST GIVE BACK AND MOVE ON
WITH MY LIFE BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE
I WILL ALWAYS CONTINUE TO FIGHT
FOR THE JUSTICE, EQUALITY AND
BETTERMENT OF MARGINALIZED
PEOPLE EVERYWHERE.
>> Tucker: A COUPLE OF PRETTY
OBVIOUS QUESTIONS.
WHAT IS THIS MOVEMENT HE REFERS
TO?
IS HE IN CONTACT WITH OTHER
PERPETRATORS FOR KATE CRIMES?
HAVE THEY FORMED A UNION?
WILL THEY HOLD A CONVENTION?
HOW EXACTLY HAS SMOLLETT WHO WAS
AN ACTOR FOUGHT FOR THE JUSTICE,
EQUALITY OF MARGINALIZED PEOPLE?
WAS POURING BLEACH ON HIMSELF
PART OF THAT?
HOW DID HE NIGERIAN
BODY BUILDERS FIGURE INTO THIS?
WHY AREN'T THE REST OF US
LAUGHING AT THIS.
IT IS TOO ABSURD.
CNN DOESN'T THINK IT IS FUNNY.
THEY ARE TAKING HIM VERY
SERIOUSLY AS THEY ALWAYS HAVE.
JEFF SMOKER'S TINY SPOKESMAN
SAID THIS WAS A MYSTERY OF
FAITH, LIKE THE SHROUD OF TURIN.
>> THE NARRATIVE CHANGED FROM
VICTIM TO VILLAIN AND THEN BACK
TO VICTIM.
IT HAS BEEN VERY CONFUSING.
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
BELIEVE AND WE MAY NEVER KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANT ON THE STREET
THAT NIGHT AND CHICAGO.
>> Tucker: WE MAY NEVER REALLY
KNOW!
AND LOOKS LIKE WE WILL HAVE TO
AGREE TO DISAGREE ON THIS WHOLE
JUSSIE SMOLLETT THING.
DOES ANYONE KNOW ANY NEWS
REPORTERS?
THEY SHOULD HAVE SOME FREE TIME
THESE DAYS, POST-RUSSIA
HYSTERIA.
MAYBE THEY COULD FIND OUT MORE
ABOUT THIS.
WHY ISN'T HE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TWO WHITE RACISTS HE SAID
ATTACKED HIM?
SHOULDN'T YOU BE LEADING THE
CHARGE TO LOCK THESE BALLOONS U
UP?
ACCORDING TO HIM, THEY ARE STILL
ON THE LOOSE.
THEY CAN ATTACK OTHER ACTORS.
WE NEED TO STOP THEM BEFORE THEY
DO.
WHAT ABOUT THE CHICAGO POLICE
DEPARTMENT?
IT IS LED BY AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN
SHEEP BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN IT
IS NOT PART OF THE WIDER RACIST
CONSPIRACY.
IT MUST BE.
CHICAGO COPS JUST FRAMED JUSSIE
SMOLLETT AS A LIAR AND DESTROYED
HIS REPUTATION.
FOR SOME REASON HE DOES NOT SEEM
TO CARE ABOUT THAT.
HE SAYS HE WANTS TO MOVE ON.
THAT IS ODD.
WHAT ABOUT THE NIGERIAN
BROTHERS?
LAST MONTH BOTH R.KELLY AND THE
"CHICAGO TRIBUNE" REPORTED THEY
HAD TOLD POLICE HE HAD READ
REHEARSED THE ATTACK.
WITHOUT A LIVE?
WILL HE SUE THEM FOR DEFAMATION?
OTHER OUTLETS SAY HE DISCOVERED
ROPE, BLEACH AND MASKS AND THE
BROTHER'S APARTMENT.
APPARENTLY HIS PHONE RECORDS
SHOW HE WAS TALKING TO THE
BROTHERS IMMEDIATELY BEFORE AND
AFTER THE ATTACK.
WHAT WAS THAT ALL ABOUT?
WE COULD GO ON AND ON.
WHY BOTHER?
WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE.
HE ISN'T GETTING OFF BECAUSE HE
IS AN ASCENT.
HE IS NOT AN ASCENT.
HE IS BETTER IS FAMOUS.
THE CHARGES AGAINST HIM WERE
DROPPED BECAUSE SOMEONE IN POWER
CALLED SOMEONE ELSE IN POWER AND
SIDE LET HIM GO.
NONE OF THIS HAD ANYTHING TO DO
WITH JUSTICE, THE OPPOSITE.
FAMOUSLY CORRUPT CHICAGO, IT WAS
TOO OBVIOUS.
THE MAYOR TENDED TO BE VERY
SHOCKED BY IT.
>> IF YOU WANT TO SAY YOU ARE
INNOCENT, YOU TAKE YOUR DAY IN
COURT.
I WOULD NEVER IF SOMEONE ACCUSED
ME, I WOULD NEVER HIDE BEHIND A
BROKEN DEAL.
WHERE'S THE ACCOUNTABILITY IN
THE SYSTEM?
YOU CANNOT HAVE BECAUSE OF A
POSITION, ONE SET OF RULES APPLY
TO THEM AND ANOTHER SET OF RULES
APPLY TO EVERYONE ELSE.
IN ANOTHER WAY YOU ARE SEEING
THIS PLAY OUT IN UNIVERSITIES
WHERE PEOPLE PAY EXTRA TO GET
THEIR KIDS A SPECIAL POSITION IN
UNIVERSITY.
THIS IS A WHITEWASH OF JUSTICE.
>> Tucker: A WHITEWASH OF
JUSTICE.
HOW TO THE STATES ATTORNEY
DROPPED THESE CHARGES ANSWER
THAT?
THEY ISSUED A STATEMENT SAYING
THE CHARGES WERE DROPPED BECAUSE
OF HIS VOLUNTEER SERVICE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
OKAY, WHAT WAS THAT SERVICE?
ACCORDING TO A NEWS ACCOUNT, HE
SPENT A TOTAL OF 18 HOURS OVER
TWO DAYS OF THE LOBBYING
ORGANIZATION.
WHILE HE WAS THERE HE SPENT HIS
TIME AND THIS IS A DIRECT QUOTE,
STUFFING MEMBERSHIP ENVELOPES
AND WORKING IN THE GROUPS
BOOKSTORE TO SELL MERCHANDISE
AND CRITIQUING IT SATURDAYS
BROADCAST.
HE ALSO WORKED WITH THE MUSIC
DIRECTOR ON A PLAN TO BUILD THE
CHOIR.
APPARENTLY THE COMMUNITY WAS
GREATLY ENRICHED BY ALL OF THIS.
WE SHOULD NOTE THAT JESSE
JACKSON WHO RUNS IT IS ONE OF
THE MOST POLITICALLY POWERFUL
PEOPLE IN CHICAGO.
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE IT, TRY IT
YOURSELF.
GO ON IN STAGE EIGHT VACATE
CRIME IN WHICH YOU SLANDER OR AN
ENTIRE GROUP OF PEOPLE ON THE
BASIS OF THEIR SKIN COLOR AND
THEN HEAD OVER TO QUIT OVER
AMERICA AND CONDUCT A TEARFUL
INTERVIEW.
DESCRIBE YOURSELF AS A VICTIM OF
RACISM IN THIS COUNTRY AND THEN
GET CAUGHT DOING IT.
TELL US HOW YOU DO?
LET US KNOW IN THE VISITING
HOURS ARE.
HE IS NOT GOING TO PRISON.
HE WAS SMARTER THAN THAT.
HE KNEW HE WOULD NEVER BE
PUNISHED.
HE KNOWS JESSE JACKSON AND HIS
FRIENDS WITH KAMALA HARRIS,
BARACK AND MICHELLE OBAMA.
JUSSIE SMOLLETT MAY CLAIM IT TO
FIGHT FOR MARGINALIZED PEOPLE
BUT HE IS NOT ONE OF THEM.
IN FACT HE OCCUPIES THE HIGHEST
RANK A PRIVILEGE AND OUR
SOCIETY.
HE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
THERE SEEM TO BE QUITE A FEW
PEOPLE LIKE THAT AND THIS
COUNTRY.
YOU WILL RECOGNIZE THEM BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE ONES LECTURING YOU